at the age of 30 immunologist underlayer
up lhasa has already achieved what many
scientists only dream of last year she
made a breakthrough in her field and
published her findings in major
scientific journals now she's been
honored with a poll Elish and lucas
darmstadt a prize for young medical
researchers it's English and quad man's
ish everybody echidnas a limited
ultimately I'm pleased at the results
that brought me the prize the
achievement that led to it and it's a
great feeling to get this recognition
for my achievement from toilets Bethulia
up lhasa has been working at the
university of bonn since 2008 she
discovered her love for medical research
while still a student originally she
wanted to work on cancer but then she
began to research the immune system her
fascination with a field has continued
to grow
at Bond University Hospital pure
research is closely linked to day-to-day
medical practice so uh Plaza can work
with specimens from patients and test
her hypothesis against clinical symptoms
she says a lot has happened in the past
few years to make Germany more
attractive to research scientists stop
definitely starting to I think that as
far as training for young scientists is
concerned Germany is in the process of
changing I think German universities and
the business community have recognized
how important it is to support young
scientists in their career planning to
point the way to career opportunities
Lukashenka yeah a week for two rising up
Lhasa is investigating how the immune
system recognizes viruses and bacteria
and then targets them she's discovered
new receptors and messenger molecules
that communicate threats to neighboring
cells that helps trigger a rapid immune
response miconazole I'm Suzanne I
synesthesia feel you could compare what
we're doing to industrial espionage in a
way we want to find out how these
mechanisms work in nature which will
hopefully allow us to use them in a
treatment framework and she'll leave
bham soon to take up a post at the Swiss
Federal Institute of Technology in
Lausanne as an assistant professor there
she'll set up her own research team
I know that's in a play on the one hand
i'm looking forward to it on the other
I'm a little in on it's a different kind
of responsibility but of course I'm glad
it will be an exciting time keeps life
interesting in Lausanne applause our
plans to investigate how the immune
system works within individual cells an
area where there are still many
unanswered questions maybe one day
she'll make another groundbreaking
discovery